i spoke to many of these
muslim former muslim agnostic muslim
moderate muslim whatever you want to
call them guys saying
if we don't take the lead in breaking
this thing open
the countries that we have fled to are
going to look like
the countries we fled from
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
human rights activist
a fellow at stanford university's hoover
institute
a best-selling author whose new book
prey immigration
islam and the erosion of women's rights
is out right now ayaan hirsi ali welcome
back to the reuben report
thank you so much david thank you for
having me on well i'm thrilled to have
you on uh we were just discussing right
before we started we we've done this a
couple times we'd
prefer to do it in person but we are
left to the wires of skype
so i want to talk about the book
obviously and that's what we're mostly
going to do today
but since i haven't chatted with you at
least publicly in about a year
how's the year been for you how you
doing what do you make of the state of
the world my friend
well it's it's different isn't it
and that's obviously an understatement i
belong to the category of people
um for whom covet has actually been a
good thing
in the sense that i can be very close to
my family
and i have never been more productive in
my life
because we've killed the commute time
right
we are not going to the office we are
not commuting
to um the places where i speak you know
it would take me
at least three days to give one single
speech and
and now it's zoom calls back to back
and that's the nature of our life um
but again having said that
i know that there are millions and
millions of people um
whose livelihoods are compromised that's
really sad
a lot of societies have cracked their
economies
people are going through all sorts of
mental health issues
domestic violence has gone up and
i couldn't wait for this thing to end i
hate kovic
are you are you shocked even though even
though it's been okay for you and and
truth be told in terms of my my life
and my businesses it's been okay for me
but obviously there's all sorts of
horrific stuff happening as you're
addressing are you shocked though how
quickly as someone that comes from a not
very
uh free place and i think most of my
audience is is familiar with your story
are you shocked how quickly
we in the west are willing to give up
our rights and freedoms
um i don't know if the word to use is
shock i think the word that i would use
now
it's in the beginning we didn't know
what was going on
this could have been the spanish flu it
could have been
smallpox it could have been tuberculosis
and again because i
do come from africa i do come from
societies where
large numbers of people are killed by
pandemics
many of them children and the young
obviously
in the beginning i was really really
frightened
like everybody else and but then the
more we find out about the disease
the more i think our response at times
is politicized it's um
it's overwrought in in some ways it's
exaggerated
but what really bothers me the most is
that we can't even
have these conversations that if you say
maybe
like my colleague at the hoover
institution scott atlas
who's a scientist and you know if he if
he comes out and he says and
along with him many others who say wait
a second
let's reflect on these tradeoffs that
these people are demonized
and that's what bothers me the most
because i don't think that the virus
cares
if you're black or white rich or poor
religious or not
they don't care advice doesn't care
about your politics
and and so i think maybe to use the word
shocking is that i thought liberal
societies were
rational societies guided by reason
and right now we're going through a time
when reason
is not the prevailing characteristic and
that is unfortunate
that's exactly what i wanted to ask you
next actually because
uh you were gracious enough to give me a
quote on classical liberalism for my
book
and i think you've been one of the great
defenders of classical liberalism not
only intellectually but also just
by extension of your life but what i'm
seeing right now and i think this is
what you're hitting on
it seems to me we're almost at the end
of western liberalism
that that sort of the woke-ism and the
giant government stuff has
has basically enveloped liberalism
and in essence the the good few
remaining liberals are sort of modern
conservatives that that's actually what
i consider myself that
i would have never said that three years
ago do you think that's a fair
summary i think that if you
if you go to a place where you're saying
you know there is no hope
um we're going to self-destruct
um then i would say i
you know caution you on that and say we
we have had
times when we were just this divided and
really irrational so
again i'm with like people like steve
pinker on
actually things haven't been better for
humanity
if you take that long long long
trajectory
from when we stopped walking on all
fours and started walking upright
yeah no well i know that of course of
course things are better
i've read the book i think i've got it
back here uh you know pinker's book
enlightenment now um so i know things
actually
aren't that bad although we've got a
certain set of problems but i do sense
that
liberalism itself seems to be being
destroyed right now that woke-ism has
destroyed the
at the academic level uh what you're
seeing at all all of the institutions
that liberalism is in a particularly
tough spot you are absolutely right uh
liberalism by the way is uh it's it's i
would
i i'd say it's probably one of the
youngest
of um philosophies
and classical liberalism and from the
time
that the enlightenment and classical
liberalism emerged it
has always been under threat
and there's this beautiful golden age
time when it
um it triumphed and but that triumph was
um it was like a back and forth uh
you know we we only had the first and
second world wars
um in the 20th century right in that
century when
things seem people seemed to be
attracted to reason
and i think this is not going to stop um
liberalism
is once again challenged now obviously i
was really very much
engaged as you know from my background
with
the challenges that political islam
presents
and the the narrative of political islam
is
liberalism is wrong individualism is
wrong universalism is wrong
and only the way they see and the utopia
of their goals is the right way
and that the way you achieve that is
through violence
sacrifice um through misogyny and
through all sorts of other
affronts to the idea and philosophy of
liberalism
now what's interesting with the work
ideology is that it is
actually a byproduct of liberalism that
it is a disappointment
with the world and so if you read that
book i
i sent it to everybody i could send it
to cynical theories
i haven't i have it i've had james on
yeah i two
i would say modern day liberals um helen
blackrose and james lindsey
what they're trying to show us is that
if you dig
deep and that's what they've done deep
into the philosophies that inform
what we now call walkism cancer culture
critical theory
critical race theory it goes by many
names
but that is an unintended consequence of
liberalism
appointment with modernity it's a
disappointment with civilization
it's a yearning for some kind of utopia
it does use secular
arguments and underpinnings but it does
have a religious
quality to it
i i've i've compared it with radical
islam
you know they want to shut down free
inquiry
you have those who are in and those who
are out
they are willing that you know they
don't want to have a conversation with
you they want to destroy you
they they they divide a society
into subsets of groups they deny
objective truth
they're hostile to science hey by the
way
they say they are standing up for women
and gays and transgender people and so
on but
if you look at what they're saying
they're actually the most racist
misogynistic people in the world and so
in that sense
i would say here's a new challenge to
liberalism
it shouldn't surprise us if you're a
true classical liberal
you know that
the challenges ideological philosophical
challenges to liberal arts
they're commonplace they'll stay with us
because that's what human nature
demands and so um
i that's why that's why i don't want to
go to a place where we are saying
this is the end of liberalism or the end
of
free society i think we should just
um how else it's like aging yeah
yeah yeah liberalism will forever be
challenged we just have to be aware
and conscious of that and even after
radical islam is defeated walking ism is
defeated
like so national socialism was defeated
and all sorts of other fascistic ideas
but it's not going to go away something
is going to come
in a new disguise that will be new to
the people who will be living through
that time
yeah you know it's interesting when i
talk about sort of the end of the road
for liberalism
what what it means to me is that now i
feel that i can do much more work
helping to liberalize or or even use
some libertarian principles
with my conservative friends that seems
like a smart place to put energy for me
as opposed to trying to fix the woke
part of this thing
but i think this is the challenge for
for all of the liberals at the moment is
is sort of which way do you go
which way do you go well what i'm seeing
is yes you have to find
allies and alliances and um
if you stop so first of all we have to
go back to you know the american
americans call classical liberalism they
call it conservatism
and the europeans just call it
liberalism that's where it all emerges
um in any case i think and the most
important thing for all of us to do
right now
is find that center ground now
talk people who are on the center left
on the center right
and make this attempt once again
to marginalize the fringes and the
extremists
and in in that sense i share your
concern
that the center is kind of sagging right
now
and we have to make these huge efforts
to go back there go back to sanity
our work is cut out for us my friend
it's gonna be our work
all right so i want to talk uh obviously
about the book and two things before we
get into the sort of
fill the full part of it but on the
opener of the book on the very first
page
you issue a trigger warning and i
thought that that was
that was quite interesting it says this
is a trigger warning
for the entry book reading it you should
be
triggered now a lot of my audience is
going to say wait a minute we don't like
trigger warnings on these things
why put a trigger warning on such a book
well it's a proclamation to take on
the woke and some of the people who
actually don't even know that they are
work
or that they've subscribed to this
ideology
and it's also
my way of saying that if we want to go
back
to the center in other words if
we want to address some of the most
confounding issues of our day
that you have to go back to that table
and in good faith
and say and be open and honest these are
the problems we are having
now what we've seen i work you know i'm
an academic
i'm in the academic space um we are
constantly bombarded
with um
you know you have to to be mindful of
and sensitive to um students
feeling unsafe about this and unsafe
about that and microaggressions and
uh so the the the walk ideology uh
that used to be fringe it has now become
mainstream
points where you know at stanford you
just get all these emails that are
telling you
what you can and can't do what you can't
and can't say
there's more political and philosophical
activism in a way that i have never seen
before
and so i think you then start with
i'm actually taking this on i want to
trigger you
i think you go to school you go to
university
to learn how to think to address you
know
when you're admitted to university
there is an assumption that you're a
grown up
ready to take on the world and take on
all sorts of challenges that come your
way
if you are demanding a safe space
it's you know it was amusing
a few years ago mildly yeah
monthly right now it's just downright
creepy
yeah and it's and it's sort of taking
over everything so one of the things
that i really liked that you did with
the book and this will get us to some of
the topics
is that i know from writing a book now
that organizing a book in and of itself
is
is sort of a tough task just figuring
out
what goes where and that's obviously
where editors help and everything but
you basically lay out the book
in four parts um and i thought we could
just go through each one
and and cover a little bit from each one
so so part one is the unsafe street
um oh you know and before we actually
get to that another thing that you
mentioned in the beginning of the book
is that because of covid it did delay
uh publication for about eight months or
so
um so that you know some of the numbers
actually may be slightly changed and
some of the behaviors
which is more interesting related to
immigration do you want to just address
that at all just because a lot has
changed in terms of
borders and allowing people in because
of covid not necessarily because of
what the strict european or or unstrict
european regulations were
yeah so i absolutely right so the first
the first um thing that you will notice
with the yeah
the manuscript is it was supposed to be
released in june of last year
and then it didn't
move some stuff was happening
i think the first thing that happened is
you have the data
is moving or the process of data
gathering
so when the book goes to press we have
official statistics um for
the countries and the societies that
actually do collect data
and that stuff changes so by the time
you know we're releasing the book now in
february things have changed people have
been confined to their homes
and you know anybody who's an opponent
of um airing this particular problem
will say
what are you talking about there are no
issues to talk about
but why well there are women on the
streets
there's nothing on the streets there's a
huge lockdown
stuff like that so the first thing is um
the challenge of updating that
data by the way very very difficult to
gather
to begin with on the other one point i
make there are lots of points but the
one point i really want
and that has struck me in the age of the
pandemic
is how governments were dragging their
feet about this issue
the issues of islam and immigration and
the integration or the attempts to try
and develop programs to assimilate
muslim minorities into european
societies and
you know a lot of it was
they had come to the conclusion we can't
do anything about it
because any attempt to address these
issues
would either empower the far right or
it would compromise our liberties
then the pandemic comes along and our
liberties are completely compromised
and we're going along with it right and
and you you also make the argument in
the book that the more
that we don't talk about those things
that you actually empower the far right
at that point because if they go oh well
if no one in a
in a civil liberal society will deal
with these honest challenges that we
have well then congratulations you're
just going to hand it
all to the far right exactly
so when we talk about the pandemic the
conversations we have
most of it is these governments have
screwed it
all up and then we get into
how things were screwed up but this is
within
the time space of just 12 months even
less than 12 months
and then you look at how things were
screwed up when it comes to immigration
islam
integration and the parallels are
fascinating so so in an odd sense did
the last year because of the way
countries are dealing with their borders
did it
slow down some of this stuff in some of
these countries because borders were
paid attention to maybe a little bit
more carefully just because of covid
not because of immigration specifically
if if in the past you talked about
borders
and immigration you would be
designated the status of the xenophobe
and racist and
you know you know the labels yes
um and so if if you raise the question
of
hey germans french
uk the netherlands scandinavia why don't
we first talk about
assimilating the people we already have
within our borders
before we let in new groups and then
at that point you're having a
conversation about borders
and the knee-jerk
conventional response would be
orders what are you talking about and
then
we'll follow then along comes kovit and
everybody's closing their borders
and not only that if i were to fly from
where i am now
to any of those european countries i
would be
forced to quarantine for 14 days
in my hotel or home or what have you
and there you have i just face
violation of your freedom of movement
and your freedom of association and even
in some discussions about kovid
your freedom of speech
and then you say but if you're not
really so you we we would say
we couldn't close borders right we
couldn't talk about borders but now all
we talk about is
come on so in an odd sense that's the
silver lining to this
right i mean that's your argument
basically is that maybe we will be able
to have these conversations because we
realize we can do some things at borders
and it doesn't necessarily make you
racist
it doesn't make you racist to say as
elected officials in government
who have been honored with
the responsibility of allocating the
resources that taxpayers
and pay and you know the legislative
process to say and and most of us you
have i have
all of us we've all complied with what
we've been told
by those people that we elected stay in
your homes wear your masks
keep the six feet distance use the hand
sanitizer
and we're all willing to do that and
we're very rational about it i know
there are a lot of people who are
irrational but most people are rational
about it
if you bring that same
rational thinking or at least the good
faith
let's talk about islam let's talk about
immigration let's talk about
assimilation
let's talk about the impact that stuff
is having on women
immigrant women muslim women women in
general which is the subject of the book
i think we would then you would say
that's an
optimistic then we've learned our
lessons as societies
the the the opposite way of doing that
putting taboos in things that will
empower the radical islamists
russian trolls it will empower the
extreme right wing
it will open the door
to authoritarians let me give you an
example
look at the government of china
when they are confronted
with radical islamic terrorism
their way of doing things is interning
the entire
muslim community like that's 10 million
strong in china
brainwashing them committing genocide
forcibly sterilizing the women we don't
want to go there we don't
literally happening right now what
you're talking about literally happening
right
now
that's what happens when you refuse to
talk about things
then you open the door for
authoritarianism what i'm proposing in
the book is
not authoritarianism it's like let's
develop
programs that introduce to young men
from societies that are misogynistic
and homophobic and
where male aggression is either
encouraged
or people are just powerless to do
anything about it
when these young men come into our
societies
let's socialize them into
freedom equality
human rights let's respect their dignity
their human rights and teach them to
respect that of others
we have the time to do that we can do it
that's what covid has shown us like if
we wanted to like
get the resources out there develop the
programs
and incentivize people
to to adopt these values and change
their behaviors
we can do it do you think this is
something that that europe has just
failed at in a way that the united
states hasn't and and
maybe the united states is starting to
fail at it a little bit in
in terms of what locism is doing meaning
that the the idea of multiculturalism in
europe
which is sort of oh you can sort of live
separately
in these countries that's very different
than the united states which was
the melting pot and is the melting pot
still
yeah so i think what saves the united
states
from perhaps going down the path of
europe is that there is this
uh concept and lived experience of the
melting pot
again that's challenged now by
not just the islamists and all sorts of
external adversaries but
also by this homegrown
woke walkism cancer culture ideology
so in america i think at least we have
the experience we know what it is
to have a melting point about melting
pots
and and we also um reaped
the benefits of that uh i would say the
average american is actually quite
has a quite a positive attitude toward
immigration and hatred and trying other
cultures and so on
in europe the story is different
and not all european countries
equal in their
incompetence or or lack of of doing
something
so i think denmark is doing a good job
now
of uh acknowledging okay we have a
problem we're gonna set these programs
up and they're having those debates they
don't agree
but think about this the social
democratic party which is center left
is actually in denmark implementing the
most
far-reaching assimilation programs in
europe
same goes for austria we are seeing
the president of france macron
and you know what these parallel
societies this islamist separatists
ghettos we can't have that we're going
to have to do something about it and
he's willing
to put his political life on the line
for that
so i'm seeing changes i'm seeing
differences in different countries
some countries like sweden that's a
total basket case
but in germany again i think germans are
now
truly frightened by the emergence of
these far-right
groups and uh actually beginning to deal
with
the issue so the united kingdom
again you know i'm seeing changes
um silver linings if you want to put it
that way
um but still not um
of the magnitude like the situation
hasn't been prioritized
to the extent say that the pandemic was
yeah it's just so interesting to me how
you can
link this to woke-ism and cancel culture
and everything else because when i was
in sweden when i was on tour with jordan
peterson a couple years ago
we were supposed to do one show it sold
out literally in two minutes
so we added another show and i i chatted
with people
actually during the show and then after
saying well what's going on here that
that jordan's message
about the individual and and liberalism
why is it so important
and everyone said because political
correctness had gotten so out of control
that they couldn't talk
about immigration they couldn't talk
about
gender or or any of the other things
that you're talking about here
and it's like well that's exactly the
purpose of the book so you lay it out in
in four parts that i really like so
first you talk about the unsafe streets
i think this is the part when people
when people see videos from germany and
france and some other places i think
this is the part that's probably the
easiest to identify with but can you
talk about that a little bit
yeah so that that part has to do with it
it became
incredibly difficult to find the data to
just
call these offices and say can you just
give me the statistics
of sexual violence in your country
and then you get into all sorts of oh
yeah
right i'll call you back tomorrow
the dragging of the feet and then they
give you studies that tell you nothing
and sometimes people will say i will
share with you the data but
you know what i don't want my name or my
occupation
anywhere i don't want my fingerprints on
it
and so it was okay but you know what the
book has i've
i everything is in there that i could
find
then the next thing is well how can i
illustrate
the problem without only leaning on just
anecdotes and now you go to the
neighborhoods
and some of the women will just really
take you
david uh to parts of sweden parts of
france parts of belgium
scandinavia anywhere and they'll say
look around what what do you miss what
are you not seeing here
um there's a swedish i think he was a
prime minister but a senior politician
in sweden who was taken to some of these
neighborhoods and he was asked the same
question like
what's missing here and he couldn't come
up with an answer he looked around
what the hell is missing here women
yeah and why
is that because
the sexual violence and the sexual
misconduct the harassment
the lewd cat calls the obscenities
that feeling that you're not safe where
you are
um and that the rule of law so the
people who are actually
supposed to do something about this are
not doing anything about it
anyway a victim of sexual violence
is less likely to go and report
so it is in terms of the different sorts
of crime it's the least reported
crime so a lot of these women have made
up their minds
and they're behaving like the women from
the
countries of origin of the man who are
responsible for most of these violent
acts
they're deleting themselves erasing
themselves
out of some of these neighborhoods and
the funny
i mean i don't think it's funny but i
think it's sad the sad thing is
that that's not shrinking it's expanding
so there are and more spaces that are
becoming women free
and then it also sort of leaks into all
sorts of other crimes right too i mean
it's not just that so women are
basically staying at home or staying
afraid or not going out
but then it's it's all the other crimes
that seem to exist and when
they send police officers in it usually
doesn't go that well
it doesn't go wrong so it's not only
women who are raising themselves out of
these spaces
it's for instance jewish minorities
erasing themselves
gay men and women they're adapting
when i say adapting so that's where
integration is going the wrong way
and when i lived in the netherlands to
say oh integration has to go both ways
and some of these places you can see
where it's going right
and and i've heard in you know during
the course of doing the research for
this book
some of the officials saying wait a
second we recognize that there is a big
problem there's nothing we can do about
it and there's also this terrible
reality that you arrest these young men
for sexual misconduct and they go into
prison as rapists they come out as
terrorists
a prison system is just horrific
and uh because of that you know let them
just
i'd rather that they're raping women
than they're terrorizing
you know it's like the craziest
trade-offs you've ever heard yeah it's
it's extraordinary so so part two um
which we've sort of hit on a little bit
but the european establishment
abrogates responsibility for women's
safety now we thought
that these liberal societies were
supposed to stand up for their women but
we're not seeing this i mean everyone
knows what happened in germany a couple
years ago on new year's
there's a lot of examples of in essence
these countries
throwing women under the bus in the name
of diversity or something like that
so about 10 years ago maybe a little
more maybe a little less
i had a discussion with my friend
christopher caldwell
who wrote a lot about immigration in
europe
and the consequences intended unintended
positive and negative
and i said to him um he said we were
talking about european values
and i said to him you know one day
the europeans they probably won't stand
up for freedom of speech they won't
stand up for this
value they won't stand up for that value
but you know what
when their women are threatened they'll
stand up for women's rights
and he just took on that expression of
you know the wise old man and he said
you're so optimistic i don't know if
they
stand up for anything wow and
i'm just i i'm terrified to say
that he was right and i was wrong do you
think that was just
naivete on your part i mean you you come
from a place where you you knew about
these things i mean do you think that
was just sort of a
an optimist way of looking at the world
that oh when it really starts affecting
these people they will do something
or do you view human nature a little
differently after a couple years
i think the first thing i'll say is
because i was surrounded by
european women who were strong and who
had fought for all of this stuff and
gained it and took it for granted i
thought
they would be first in line to say this
is
unacceptable um
so i think that maybe it's it's uh
it blew me uh let me see i don't know
it misdirected me into thinking
that you know there's gonna be i know
there were all sorts of
confrontations happening but when you
come for the little girls and you come
for the women
you know society is going to say that's
a red line
and so i have to confess that i got that
wrong
i think i also got wrong the class
element
that wealthy middle-class women
with university degrees um
organize their organizing around causes
such as the glass
ceiling they want to be ceos they want
to
be on board leaderships and stuff like
that
they want to be chancellors and prime
ministers and that's what excites them
and it was a lot of conversation about
child care so that you could have 50
of parliament be female
and that's what middle-class women are
preoccupied with
and i didn't realize that there was that
disconnect
between working-class women and
middle-class wealthier women and that's
what i'm seeing now
and maybe that's why in the beginning
when we were just talking about
immigrant women muslim women
you know stuff that they're subjected to
most people were looking away because
it was you know not just foreign
and they didn't understand it
um but it was also you know it wasn't
their problem right so that's what's so
fascinating about it because when it was
just sort of their
problem in their in their own ghettos
sort of separate okay that's one thing
but then when you add this element of
cultural relativism where you're no
longer allowed to say i mean this is
what we've seen we see women get raped
on the streets we
we read about grooming gangs although
you don't really hear anything in
mainstream media here
but if you read those things and you
well you can't say
you can't you're not allowed to say that
those people those specific people who
hold those specific views
that those views are worse than our
views everything's equal
everything is equal and they've been
saying that for a very long time
um david i spoke to tinos henandagi who
is
a swedish economist a long time ago i
should have mine again
yeah he told me he was on my podcast
i interviewed him for the book um he
said to me
that there is an interesting development
that the people who are actually coming
out now and talking about these things
are immigrant men and women
and i asked him do you think that there
is a possibility that working class
women
local native white women could actually
ally
with immigrant women and and immigrant
families who've had enough of the crime
who've had enough of the disruption you
know remember they fled their campaigns
in searching for better life in search
of stability and predictability
and they're now being confronted with
this mess
what is the likelihood that working
class
families men and women but especially
women
and immigrant women could actually form
an alliance and fight this thing
uh he's optimistic on that he said in
sweden
you know they're the ones at the
forefront of people who are trying to
break open the taboos
are immigrant women so immigrant women
immigrant men
immigrants i spoke to mustafa pangshiri
i spoke to
um mohamed abdul samid in in germany i
spoke to many of these
muslim former muslim agnostic muslim
moderate muslim whatever you want to
call them guys saying
if we don't take the lead in breaking
this thing
open um the countries that we have
fled to are going to look like the
countries we fled from
yeah and then of course as you know our
our friend majin nawaz who started
quilliam in the uk who hates him
it's the lefties it's the lefties that
hate him right i mean he who's always
trying to cancel him
even right now trying to get his radio
show off lbc
it's the lefties because they're now
trying to frame him
a muslim man from egypt uh as a racist i
mean it's
you know a little something about this
from your own story
he went to egypt when he was radicalized
but i think his heritage
probably lies somewhere in pakistan um
but it's exactly it's exactly it's
exactly it's the demonization of
anybody who wants to break this open and
i think that they are becoming less and
less successful because
you now see the rise of the far right
you see the rise of populist parties
you see this despair again i want to go
as an example to the to the president of
france
who has to you know he is he has to
defend
his presidency from marie le pen
um and developments like that
and the far left will continue to try
and
silence everyone but they're not
succeeding because people are
suffering we i'm i'm you know what the
book tries to do is
some of the animals that's a description
of real human
pain and so the more you say to
i told you some of the victims they say
i'm not far right i i i'm for
immigration i work for left-wing parties
but i've been raped
i've been subjected to this type of you
know sexual violence
and i don't want that right of course
well you don't want everyone to have to
be raped
in essence to wake up right like that's
what we're trying to stop here
that's what we're trying to stop we're
trying to stop the crimes and so the i
think there's we are maybe at a moment
in some european countries more than
others i think that's where denmark got
to it's a smaller population
austria they were talking about a rape
epidemic i mean just
think about that before the pandemic
they were talking about
a rape epidemic and that's what forced
the authorities to do something about
these things and so
these attempts at silencing people by
labeling them taking away as you
describe magics
podcasts and platforms and things like
that it's not going to work
it's not going to and i'm old enough let
me tell you this
i mean i love the internet
i'm a proponent of the internet i think
it's one of the best things that
happened in my lifetime
but i'm old enough to know when there
was no internet
when were cell phones um when very few
people had landlines
and yet we communicated so you can
you know the tech giants can say i'm
gonna
take your platform away good luck with
that
but people will find ways to communicate
but the sad story is
if you say we are going to marginalize
and
silence certain views
you then have to deal with the
unintended consequences of censorship
and censorship
never works never worked yeah we we know
they're gonna find a way to communicate
no matter what way to communicate yeah
remember martin luther
right they're going to figure it out if
they have to nail a uh you know a piece
of paper on a door
they're they're going to figure it out
um
yeah you've mentioned germany a couple
times this is sort of a little bit part
three is clash
clashing civilizations revisited
germany's sort of a unique case because
they obviously
are only you know 70 years off or
no about 90 years now off the off the
holocaust
um they have a very strange situation
where there's a lot of guilt
in in some cases very unearned guilt for
young people that just happen to
to grow up german but now because of the
immigration situation there does seem to
be a new
right growing there a new far right
let's say
what what could you tell us about what's
going on in germany
well a number of things are going on in
germany and this is
um here's like the great paradox of our
day because
um like you said just about
90 or so years ago they were trying to
occupy the rest of europe
um they were obviously
they have a lot to atone for but um
carrying out the holocaust and
trying to gas and eliminate um
different types of minorities and the
paradox today is that they are
leading in this european unification
project
so on the one hand that project
is just so time consuming and source
consuming
and they want to get the buy-in of all
of these other european countries and
their populations
but on the other hand they have to
attend for all of that stuff
that they did in the past and their past
is way more raw
and way more recent than let's say the
other are the other
european countries and so they want to
demonstrate
that they are in fact no longer racist
that they have given up on
what that you know their national
identity
and is is
for a lot of people germany just means
occupation invasion holocaust
crime crime crime against human beings
so they are turning for that
and and so they want to illustrate yeah
look we are welcoming
immigrants we are we are different
you know they want to show that they
have changed
david you can't fix
the problems of today
by trying to fix what you didn't do in
the past
and that that black spots
on the german past will will always be
there
just like in america you know we we did
engage in slavery and in segregation and
we deny the fellow human beings their
civil rights
that will never go away that will be
part of our history
the holocaust will be part of germany's
history
but you can't fix that by saying we're
going to throw women to the wolves now
do you think do you think merkel it's
too late
for her because you know she at first
was one of the big proponents of opening
borders and let as many people in as
possible and
give i mean there was a huge problem a
couple years ago where they were giving
so many social services to all of these
new
immigrants that that new immigrants or
people that had been there for 10 years
started getting upset
but now she's kind of backtracked on
that and has gone a little more hard
line but
do you think it's kind of too late well
she's leaving anyway
there'll be someone else um and then
they'll they'll have to choose a party
leader and then
we'll have elections and i hope they'll
end up
with um figures from the center whether
it's center left or center right
i think early on in her leadership
angela merkel was a
fresh voice a fresh face
but then as time went on you you know
you get that whole thing about power
corrupts
and i don't think she's a corrupt person
i just think
maybe power makes people tone deaf
and she was tone deaf to
the failure of the integration process
and so how flinging the doors open
when the integration process had failed
so miserably
i think that was a failure of leadership
now that is a very harsh judgment coming
from me
and i know i don't know what i would
have done in her position
but when i spoke to some of the german
senior people there they were saying
that it was done
that's 2015.
okay let's there will come in culture uh
let's just open the doors let's
let everyone in they said there was no
there was no thoughts it was thoughtless
um and that didn't only cause problems
in germany
it caused problems all across europe
and it also caused problems to that eu
project that they were spending so much
time and energy on
and that and that's how the people talk
that i've spoken to in german
yeah i mean in many ways at least partly
that was what fueled brexit i mean it
was mostly an economic thing but it
obviously had to do with borders and
immigration as well
absolutely and you know we talk about
buy in right
by in trying to persuade leaders of
different countries
that have different cultures in
different languages and trying to
persuade
their populations to subscribe to the
european project
and then you do something like this you
know you just say okay
uh i don't really care that's that's the
message the unintended message maybe
that you are
conveying and yeah i would say a lot had
to do with
when it comes to brexit a lot had to do
with
that tone-deaf attitude to islam
immigration
the clash of values and same
with countries like hungary europe
sorry poland um some of these eastern
european countries that have taken on a
harder line
toward immigration i think a lot of it
has to do with
uh them feeling that the leadership at
the core of the european project are
just not listening to them so
they're full of yeah do you think that
places like poland and hungary are just
much better suited at this point to
survive all of this
because of that i think it depends on
whether they feel that they're being
listened to and that they're not being
condescended to
it's the same experience we had here in
america where a lot of people
voted for donald trump because they felt
that they were being
condescended to that the establishment
had contempt for them and only contempt
and there are a lot of people in europe
uh some small countries some bigger
countries
who are saying you know these people in
brussels they don't see us as fellow
human beings
they they call us um racist and
xenophobia they don't see our problems
um they're full of contempt for us and
and that obviously leads
if you're a democracy and in the at the
end of the day you're going to have to
rely on
the buying the votes um you know
electoral vic
victory and then you better listen to
the people that
you want to give you power so that's
actually a perfect segue to part four
uh which is solutions fake and real
um so what are some of the fake
solutions because i feel like those are
the ones that will probably
uh end up being used at least for a
while
one fake solution is that this
web very complex web of
legislation rules agencies
um that governs immigration in europe
and that that is
to be maintained going forward that's a
fake solution it has
failed the asylum and refugee
system the immigration system that these
countries have in place are
too complex full of too many loopholes
too many special interests and when i
talk about special interest i'm not only
talking about
the um
the legitimate special interests that
lobby
these governments i'm also talking about
people's mugglers
and human traffickers so there are just
too many
it's too complex and so we have to go
and review and revisit that that's a
fake
so to carry on saying why don't we
um make a distinction between those who
qualify for asylum and those who don't
qualify for asylum this
i think that that is totally
that that has failed so people who keep
pushing that are actually really pushing
their special interests i think
the second fake
approach would be to say you know
you take a bunch of people in your
country now take a bunch of people and
so on
the reason why that is fake is how many
people could a country like denmark
or even germany even the bigger
countries
that would be like a drop in the ocean
when it comes
to the displaced peoples in the world
in fact i was reading a u.n report
yesterday that said
70 percent of the people who end up on
the shores of europe
seeking asylum will not be granted
asylum
they don't go 70 and you know what
the pandemic is going to cause food
shortages
because of food shortages there'll be
more conflict because of conflict
there'll be more displaced people so
so the trend of the millions of people
who are trying to get into europe
that's not going to go down that's only
going to go up up
so what then would be the real solution
and that would be to have a serious
conversation about push and pull factors
and you look at the push factors and the
only way to really deal
seriously with that is through a
collaboration of these
various countries and that would have to
be let's break down the silos between
the foreign affairs departments the
defense department
the development aid department the
economic
affairs department you break all that
down and you have to then figure out
a more sort of i would say
i'm getting tired now but it's like a
big picture
approach uh in sort of in
ways equal to what we're doing about the
pandemic now you know we're forcing a
lot of countries to collaborate
on compromising their economies or
sacrificing the freedoms of their
populations to say let's get this thing
under control
and i think that kind of approach would
be appropriate for the immigration
and it's not immigration immigration is
the wrong way to use here
for this mass movement of people
so one more for you which i think will
sum up everything
are you hopeful are you hopeful for the
world
at the moment i think a lot of people
are very fearful and i i've been trying
on my show every day to
to show them that they you can't just be
dominated by fear you have to be
dominated by hope
um your life story is a story of hope
are you hopeful that we can solve
not only what we're talking about here
but just sort of all of the
giant issues that seem to be confronting
us right now
and you know when you say giants you
know think back about this
it's not even so giant right now
remember when america was about to break
up
because there were people who had slaves
and people who
wanted to go to a war or to end it that
was a giant issue
the slave trade all across the world
back then was one of the most profitable
enterprises and we were able to end it
we fought who world wars
and human beings were able to recover
there are all sorts of places in the
world where all sorts of conflicts are
going on at the moment
and people are able to get out of it
recover
and leave something better for the next
generation so i am
hopeful now that we're really in a place
where
science technology
money we have so much money i think if
we put all of those resources
and we have the largest number of
educated people when i say educated i
mean
literate people who can read and write
my grandmother and my gran
and my mother could not read or write so
in the modern world
we have we have just so much to work
with
to make things better um
but do we want to do it's the political
will
and and that we people like you and me
we just have to keep harping on it
i have nothing better to do do you
no no no and so between fighting radical
is 11 walking
all right we got our work cut out for us
i guess
well the book is pray the link is right
down below
and it's just great to see you as always
and
uh hopefully in person next time my
friend
in person next time thank you so much
again for everything that you do
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about international issues instead of
non-stop yelling check out our
international playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell